Using Android Auto is easy.
Users go to the Play Store and
download apps onto their phone
that support Android Auto.
They then connect their phone to their
car, the phone goes in the car mode, and
casts the Android Auto
experience to the car's screen.
This means that although all the apps
and services are actually running on
the phone, they're displayed in the
car's dash and you interact with them
using the vehicle's controls such as
a built-in touch screen and microphone.
Now because of this,
you don't need to write a new app.
Instead, you can just extend
your existing Android apps
to work in the car.
Now there are two great use cases for
this today: audio and messaging.
Audio apps such as music,
radio, and audiobook players,
which are awesome way to stay
entertained while you're driving,
can now be extended into the car.
The APIs are available to expose
content, receive playback control, and
customize the UI.
Messaging applications,
which are a great way to stay connected
while you're driving,
can now be extended to the car as well.
APIs are available to
show notifications,
play back the message, and
even reply with speech.